[Applaudissements]
allez on remballe
le festival le festival même le premier
mot est écorchée tellement la peur est
là la peur de rentrer le festival de
cannes qui remballe ses valises ses
valoches s'appelle auch ce fraternité
ces vanités
c'est sincérité parfois le festival renc
chez lui c'est à dire chez nous rentre à
la maison après ce monde d'illusions de
rêve de colère pour rien de violences
parfois sincères et authentiques rendant
la croisette à son destin balnéaire
ces gâteaux de chantilly crème léchée
par les vagues la mer toujours
recommencée la méditerranée terrain de
jokari les cimetières
parfois pour ceux qui veulent nous
rejoindre à qui on ne sait plus tendre
la main
le festival de cannes remballe ses
hommes ses femmes qui étaient là tous
ensemble unis pour rien pour rêver pour
construire pour essayer de dire que
derrière les films derrière des images
derrière des sons y a des rêves il ya
des violences
il ya des envies de transfert des choses
pas des messages nous ne sommes pas des
postiers nous sommes simplement des gens
qu'avant eu le courage ou la chance
d'exprimer nos rêves d'aller vers les
eaux de tendre une main qu'on appelle un
film nous sommes des hommes et des
femmes ici privilégié sans doute mais
qui seront faire quelque chose de
toussaint
la chaîne la chaîne humaine la chaîne
des mains las manos sommes prêts ramano
todo la mano aller ensemble et plus loin
que restera-t-il de ce printemps là
cette 71e année l'hiver vient sans doute
mais qu'il fut beau ce printemps là
souvenez-vous ceux qui étaient là qui
ont vu les échos les belles colères de
vincent lindon filmé par stéphane brizé
souvenez vous la grâce spectaculaire de
benoît poelvoorde nageant à
contre-courant sur les marches de cannes
les poils de chewbacca triomphant
airelles puisqu'il était là là haut
souvenez vous de ces hommes et ces
femmes qui se sont aimés ensemble ou
séparément dans les films de gonzalez ou
christophe honoré
vous avez vu cet enfant qui demandait à
ses parents chez nadine labaki
pourquoi suis-je envie pourquoi tu as
envie me batte en faisant quelque chose
la grâce de ce film là souvenez vous
aussi de matteo garrone dali sera offert
je prononce mal son nom mais ne m'en
voudra pas
la résurrection tout était là la vie la
mort et la vie après bonsoir festival de
cannes je t'aime avec tes paradoxe
incroyable avec ses cris pour rien avec
ses fureurs et ses silences et vous là
haut ça va les gars ça va mon grand tu
es content c'est merveilleux quand même
on est là on est tous en location
finalement que ça va je l'avais dit
bonsoir bienvenue à la 71e cérémonie de
clôture du festival de cannes
je fais ça court
[Applaudissements]